you think if a woman hits someone she
should expect to get hit back I'm not
here for violence against women like I'm
not trying to what about self-defense
what about self-defense against my
friends but I think as a man you can
contain yourself and you know I mean
control the situation you should contact
me a knife then I've got to do I need to
do to protect my life honestly I have to
do whatever you know me whatever needs a
must I mean I'm gonna do that I have a
question if my producer at their
blessing goes up to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and hits him can Dwayne The Rock
Johnson hit him back absolutely because
you hit him I'm provoked so wouldn't you
say that's a little bit of a double
standard you have then for men and for
women because
that's a weaker Man versus a man that's
clearly stronger an offensive Last Woman
Against Woman you know what I mean it's
too fat it's too fair you know what I
mean how is it fair when Dwayne The Rock
Johnson is much stronger than him and
because Dwayne Johnson put in the
[__] work I need to put himself to
that size in it so if this happens not
shrimp that's his business you know what
I mean but I think man against man is
always going to be fair I'm gonna get
someone's gonna be fair man against
woman I'm not safe